Dark Souls 2 is shaping up to be a much
more difficult game than its predecessor
welcome again guys to Souls news an
embargo has just lifted on some more
details about Dark Souls 2 and these
these are probably the best facts we've
heard for a while so sit back relax and
let me share them with you if you want
to skip ahead to something more
interesting
check the description the three biggest
pieces of news are as follows one summon
phantoms now have a temporary lifespan -
every time you die as a hollow your
maximum health will decrease and 3 every
player is now open to invasion and
that's regardless of whether your hollow
or human well you wanted Dark Souls 2 to
be harder and that's what you got now
Dark Souls had crutches if you were
having trouble you could summon a
phantom to help you if you wanted to
avoid being invaded you could just stay
hollow well now from software just kick
those crutches out from under you and
they're about to kick you while you're
down because if you die in hollow form
your maximum health will decrease and
the level will get just that tiny bit
harder to punish you from your mistake
me I love these changes let's talk about
the summon phantoms first I hadn't
thought about this before now but it's
ingenious really if summon phantoms have
a time limit it fixes a few problems one
ganking will be more difficult and pure
it'll still happen but this changes
everything
imagine you summon help to defend you
from an invader if you don't act quickly
and kill the invader then your summoned
help will fade and you'll be left alone
to fight him now this gives the red
phantom a bit more control over the
situation than he had previously instead
of the host just waiting in a safe spot
with a bunch of summoned help you'll
actually feel threatened by an enemy who
comes into your world you'll need to get
him out as soon as possible with your
phantom so that you can progress through
the level with your partner a few other
things to note here the more enemies
your white phantom kills the less time
he has in your world this means the host
will have to do most of the work as I
said before no more crutches you can
still summon help but you'd better pull
your weight this time around now the
next thing invasions in Dark Souls there
were two states hollow and human you
could only be invaded when human in dark
souls - there's no easy way out as long
as you're connected to the net
you can always be invaded whether your
hollow human it doesn't matter you're
vulnerable wherever
go the PvP guys should be really happy
with this one not only do we have proper
servers now but now that everyone is
vulnerable imagine how much easier it
will be to invade the pool of people who
can be invaded should have just
increased dramatically now a few people
actually complain about being invaded
and even go as far as to play offline
but I don't understand those people
being threatened by other players is
part of the experience even if it's
unbalanced at times it's so exciting
trying to progress through a level with
someone in your world trying to kill you
I've never really found any other game
that gives that same adrenaline rush
that you get when someone else invades
you and this goes doubly so for launch
if you've never played a souls game at
launch then you're in for a good time
it's such an amazing experience to
explore with and against other players
who are just as overwhelmed by the game
as you are one last note on this topic
covenants are going to be much more
important this time around one covenant
in particular has leaked it's called the
way of Blu assumedly that's the name in
progress anyway when you join this
covenant when you get invaded by a red
phantom you'll get a blue phantom tasked
with protecting you from the invader the
last piece of news I've got for you guys
is regarding death in Dark Souls 2 and
this is arguably the most major mechanic
change with herds date in Demon Souls
you operated with 50% health if you're
in Sulphur you could restore to human
form and get that health back in Dark
Souls there were 2 States hollow and
human but there was no real gameplay
disadvantage to either of them now in
Dark Souls 2 every time you die as a
hollow you will lose a bit of your
maximum health I imagine it'll work like
this die once that's 10% health less die
again that's 20% health less and so on
and so on until you're left with a
minimum of 50% health to defeat the
level that's your punishment for making
mistakes now in the law hollowing is a
constant process you lose a bit of
humanity every time you die this
mechanic of losing a bit of health every
time you die actually suits the law a
bit more now a while ago from software
express that they were kind of
displeased with her humanity worked in
the original game I mean look at this I
spent hours customizing my waifu and i
end up looking like beef jerky for the
entire game now in Dark Souls 2
according to polygon humanity as an item
seems to be completely removed
apparently you restored a human via a
consumable item called
human effigy an effigy is a sacrifice so
I assume you're sacrificing someone
else's humanity to restore your own law
implications aside I assume that when
you're human you won't lose maximum
health if you're Hollow you'll be
operating at a lower life bar every time
you die and you can restore your health
bar by restoring your humanity I love
this change as well it's a tough but
fair punishment we've dealt with similar
punishments to our health bars and
previous games
you know like curse and soul form but
losing a bit of health each time is more
incremental than losing 50 percent of
your health at once so I assume their
reasoning was that you should be skilled
enough to overcome it as you learn more
about the stage you keep dying in so
those are the major points but I'm not
going to leave you just yet I'm actually
going to leave you with a few facts I
got from epic named burrows recent video
here played a demo version of the game
and he took the time to look at a few
facts that people would have missed I
recommend you watch it since he goes
really in-depth for you guys but I like
to keep it short so if you don't have 30
minutes then I'll sum up most of it here
a link to his video will be in the
description okay so casting speed is
allegedly increased by achievement magic
and fire damage seems to be increased by
intelligence lightning and dark by faith
and poison and bleed perhaps by
dexterity he calls attention to a new
stat may be called agility but he might
be mistaken
he might have mistaken this for Dex at
any rate it seems like roll speed and
animation speeds seem to be affected by
a stat now rather than exclusively by
the weight of your character now we've
theorized that rolling looks to behave
differently in previous videos so this
would account for that also parrying is
no different it seems to have a start up
before the actual parry rather than the
parry animation being instantaneous
you're going to have to adapt to that
prediction the NB notes that the enemy
falls to the ground upon the parry
itself which could mean parrying
operates as a sort of crowd control
regardless of whether you actually
follow through with a riposte again it's
been noted that enemies were really
aggressive they come in groups and
they'll chase you down aggressively
rather than slowly like in Dark Souls 1
lastly enemy management seems to be a
very big thing with combinations of
ranged and melee mobs presented together
considering we have more healing options
available to us now it makes sense that
the combat itself will increase in
difficulty
oh and also a collector's edition has
been announced for Dark Souls 2
pre-order now and EB Games Game Stop or
Amazon to get yourself a 12-inch warrior
Knight figure official soundtrack
authentic cloth game map a collectible
art book and an iron case for your game
Dark Souls always has great collector
edition so grab one while it lasts the
game releases on the 11th of March in
North America and on the 14th in Europe
and Australasia still hungry for more
Dark Souls 2 information if you like
this video then you need to see these
ones too there's two links on the screen
that will help you understand the shape
of Dark Souls 2 the video on the Left
talks about new classes how backstabs
aren't as powerful anymore and the loss
of games for Windows Live the video on
the right discusses the changes to
difficulty new healing items and the
subtle changes to enemy AI as usual
thanks so much for watching I hope
you're getting really hyped up Dark
Souls 2 is looking amazing one thing to
note in this video was that a lot of
information was available because Namco
Bandai is directly contacting those in
the community so props to them for that
anyway later guys oh wait one more thing